my next guest was an ordinary woman
working in a shop
when a stranger walked in and turned her
life upside down
his name was mark acklam he wooed
carolyn woods with stories of
wealth and success but he was in fact
one of britain's most notorious con men
he duped her out of 850 000 pounds of
savings
before going on the run and sparking an
international manhunt
sky news's crime correspondent martin
brunt spent four years tracking mark
acklum
uncovering his vast criminal network and
the people he managed to con out of
thousands of pounds well caroline has
now written a book about what happened
to her called sleeping with a psychopath
and she joins me now carolyn thank you
very much indeed for
being with us this afternoon
it is an incredible story um
and many wouldn't believe that this is a
true story
that you have written but it is your
story um
describe for me what first happened when
you met mark acklam at the time
you knew him as mark conway yes he
introduced himself to me as mark conway
um he turned up in my place of work i
was working in a lovely boutique in the
town of temporary
where i had relatively recently moved
really trying to just have a bit of an
adventure and a change of life
um having gone through some fairly
horrible
horrible but commonplace life events
in the previous few years so he walked
in he was
very very charismatic um very attractive
very amusing and entertaining and i
think even in the
first few moments i felt as though i had
known him all my life he felt like a
friend
but of course he was anything but he he
painted this picture of himself that was
mysterious was very exciting you did
right from the word go have a couple of
question marks you had a few doubts
but he managed to draw you in he was
very clever very convincing
your family though weren't as convinced
were they
well my family initially um
certainly my brother and sister-in-law
expressed some doubts but they hadn't
met him um all they knew was that i had
met a man that i
that i found fascinating and probably
described as you know
amazing um and they immediately sounded
the warning bells but unfortunately
i didn't heed them um i thought how can
you possibly judge somebody before
you've met them and probably a little
bit upset that at the thought that
um they obviously thought that nobody
like this would
show an interest in me um then my
my daughters and some friends did meet
him very briefly
um and all found him odious and
actually he was utterly diabolical even
i
found emojis on that occasion and i find
it very hard in retrospect to think
how i continued that relationship i made
excuses for him
um and they did express some doubts
but again it's quite hard to be told by
your children
that you're doing the wrong thing so um
yeah i take full responsibility for that
but i think he was very controlling of
you
carolyn though wasn't he and that
behavior started very early on when it
came to finances where it came to where
you lived
i i think that's i i was going to go on
to say i think it's just so difficult to
convey
to people who haven't been in this
situation
just how you get hooked and reeled in
and i've had some communication from
other women who've been in a similar
situation
and they understand and i think probably
before it happened to me i would have
said well
you know i i would never get conned like
that
but uh these characters and mark acklum
is particularly
clever and cunning in in this um they
are so skilled at
reading you and they sort of set a scene
that
seems to satisfy your hopes and desires
and
you do get reeled in and he's done it
not just with countless women
but with businessmen and women as well
so um
you know i try to put out a warning but
whether it's heeded
i i don't know and and whether anybody
if they were to meet him
would think you know uh just don't do it
i don't know so that is a very difficult
sort of conundrum
he told you he was a swiss banker he'd
got various different business interests
he was also
an mi6 spy at what stage
did things begin to unravel for you and
you start to uncover
who he really was
well it wasn't really until uh well into
i've been in the relationship for about
a year very miserable for most of it i
mean it was
very very exciting for the first two or
three months
and then became he started to isolate me
and i
became more and more depressed and
introverted um
and it probably wasn't until another
year when
actually i hadn't seen him for a while
he by that stage had claimed to
have a brain tumor and have had an
operation on that
um staging a very convincing
little charade to make me believe that
that had happened and that was a one of
a number of charades that he he did
stage to back up his claims
um but i think it wasn't until then and
eventually when he failed to show up
when we hadn't seen each other
for about six months and had arranged to
meet in nice
and he didn't show and i just thought
you know
nobody could do this no one claiming to
love someone could just leave them and i
was in a terrible state myself by that
stage
and i just thought no this this is this
is all wrong
because not only had you lost all of
your
life savings you'd also lost a lot of
yourself this took a huge mental toll on
you
did um i think the the isolation
uh was was really terrible and i mean i
was having panic attacks and nightmares
i felt complicit in my own downfall
in retrospect once i found out who he
was because right at the beginning of
the relationship he had
sort of sworn me to secrecy and said
that it would take him 18 months to
extricate himself from his contract with
um
mi6 and he asked me to give
give him my word that i would that i
could be strong and stand by him and i
did that
um and sadly so the sort of character
traits that i
thought of as my strengths of loyalty
and discretion
and um stoicism all those things
really um contributed it to
my own downfall although not in the end
because in the end after another very
long
battle and with the help of martin brunt
as you've described
um he was taken to court and he admitted
only five of the 20 counts against him
and he is now in jail
yeah and you mentioned martin there
because this your story may well be
familiar to sky news
viewers it is one that our crime
correspondent martin brunt
followed closely over many years this is
martin uh
tracking mark acklam down
um you worked closely with martin
to eventually see justice done
yes i mean martin was uh it was
instrumental in
apprehending mark acklum it was martin
who found him
um in prison in spain and uh these
pictures that are on screen at the
moment
are of the court case that was going on
in spain um
you know shortly thereafter so uh yes
martin found him he was the first person
to discover where he was
um but sadly uh aklum was released from
prison in spain before
the arrest warrant here could be issued
in his name
so the whole thing carried on for about
another three years i think
a very very long road to justice and a
traumatic one but how are you now
carolyn um well i'm much better than i
was
but you know we are now nine years on
from my meeting with mark acklum so
it has taken a just a very very heavy
toll i mean
i was left suicidal you know when i
found out who he was and what he'd done
to me and the sense of
betrayal and violation was really
overwhelming and
devastating but i'm slowly
sort of getting back to regaining some
confidence
and as you said i've i've written a book
which
actually i didn't find at all cathartic
but as a an intellectual exercise and
something to focus on i
do feel a great sense of achievement in
that and if i can
warn anybody and help anybody to avoid
uh becoming a victim to somebody like
mark ackland or mark ackland himself
um that will have been worthwhile
uh carolyn thank you very much indeed
for telling us
some of your story it is fascinating
horrifying terrifying in
in equal measure carolyn woods there
thank you
thank you